Traductor: Paula Motter
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Tu deportista favorita está
muy cerca de su victoria triunfal.
La multitud contiene el aliento
y, en el momento crucial, yerra el tiro.
Esa competidora acaba de experimentar
un fenómeno de bloqueo,
por el cual una persona, aun después
de meses --o años-- de práctica,
comete un error
justo en el momento decisivo.
Este bloqueo es común entre deportistas,
que a menudo deben actuar
bajo una intensa presión
y dependen de momentos clave.
Pero la ansiedad también afecta
a quienes hablan en público,
a participantes en concursos de ortografía
e incluso a músicos de renombre mundial.
De manera instintiva, adjudicamos
esa ansiedad a un estado nervioso,
pero ¿por qué ese nerviosismo
perjudica el desempeño de los expertos?
Existen dos grupos de teorías.
Ambas sostienen que el bloqueo
resultante de actuar bajo presión
está ligado, en primera instancia,
a la concentración.
Por un lado, están
las teorías de distracción.
Según ellas, el rendimiento
se resiente cuando la mente se distrae
con preocupaciones, dudas o temores,
en lugar de concentrar la atención
en realizar la tarea que nos ocupa.
Cuando los pensamientos
relevantes e irrelevantes
compiten por la misma atención,
alguno debe ceder.
El cerebro no puede procesar
mucha información a la vez.
Las tareas que desafían
la memoria de trabajo,
que es el "anotador mental"
donde almacenamos momentáneamente
números telefónicos y listas de compras,
son particularmente
vulnerables a la presión.
En un estudio realizado en 2004,
un grupo de estudiantes universitarios
debió resolver problemas matemáticos,
algunos sencillos y otros más complejos,
de gran exigencia para la memoria.
La mitad de los estudiantes resolvieron
ambos tipos de problemas
sin presión alguna,
en tanto que los otros lo hicieron
en ambas situaciones: de calma y estrés.
Todos resolvieron bien
los problemas fáciles,
pero quienes estaban estresados
tuvieron peor desempeño
en los problemas más difíciles
que exigían el uso de la memoria.
El segundo grupo de teorías que
explican el bloqueo bajo presión
son las del monitoreo explícito.
Explican cómo la presión
puede inducir a la gente
a analizar por demás la tarea
que tiene entre manos.
Estas teorías postulan que,
una vez automatizada la tarea,
el analizar su mecanismo
preciso interfiere
con la capacidad de realizarla.
Las tareas que hacemos
de manera inconsciente
parecen ser más vulnerables
a este tipo de bloqueo.
Un estudio comparó el desempeño
de golfistas profesionales
cuando se concentraban exclusivamente
en embocar la bola en el hoyo,
respecto de cuando analizaban
de manera exhaustiva
las técnicas del golpe
para embocar la bola.
Por lo general, los golfistas
hacen estos movimientos
de manera inconsciente,
por ello quienes de pronto
se pusieron a examinar
los detalles precisos de su jugada
tampoco lograron buenos
resultados y fallaron el tiro.
Pero no todos pueden evitar
el bloqueo bajo presión.
Los estudios sugieren que hay
individuos más susceptibles que otros,
especialmente las personas tímidas,
ansiosas
y temerosas del juicio
negativo de los demás.
¿Cómo se podría evitar el bloqueo
en situaciones importantes, entonces?
Primero, es bueno practicar
en situaciones de estrés.
En un estudio con expertos
lanzadores de dardos,
se descubrió que quienes no habían
practicado en situación de estrés
tenían peor desempeño
cuando se ponían nerviosos,
a diferencia de quienes se habían
habituado a actuar bajo presión.
En segundo lugar, hay quienes aconsejan
tener una rutina previa a la actuación,
como inspirar un cierto número de veces,
repetir alguna palabra en particular
o seguir una secuencia
rítmica de movimientos.
Estudios realizados sobre el golf,
el juego de bolos y el polo acuático
indican que la práctica de breves
rituales puede inducir
un desempeño más constante
y preciso bajo presión.
Y tercero, investigaciones han demostrado
que concentrarse en un objetivo externo
en el momento crucial da más resultado
que enfocarse en un objetivo interno,
donde el interés está en la mecánica
de la tarea a realizar.
Un estudio con golfistas
experimentados reveló
que quienes hacían un golpe corto
mientras se concentraban
en la trayectoria de la bola
tenían un desempeño mucho mejor
que quienes se concentraban
en el movimiento de los brazos.
Se podría entonces
modificar el viejo dicho:
la práctica,
bajo estrés,
con concentración
y con ese glorioso objetivo final en mente,
hace la perfección.